[Applause]
we've a game there is no game without
the players really it all comes down to
you I mean let me show you have a
kangaroo tonight
without you there is no game there's no
one's play it no one to interact with
its Amiga nyeh
you keep us in check and we appreciate
that
[Music]
and through all of it you're always
there with us you are definitely not
afraid to tell us how you feel
your feedback sometimes challenges us
but it forces us to be always
challenging ourselves you emphasize with
us as developers and with each other as
a community it's really beautiful I'm
Dean gabba gabba and I used to take a
week off every time if it is the game
came out my name is mark Diaz and when I
was 8 years old I used to sneak over to
my buddy's house to play - I'm rich
Lambert
Daggerfall was one of the very first
games that got me into the elderscrolls
world
I'm Dana Christo and I started out as a
16 year old gamer who just wanted to
bring joy to others through video games
and now I'm game director at Arkane
studios now I'm a game programmer at its
software now I get to be a part of
building that world as the creative
director on the Elder Scrolls online now
I'm a UI programmer at Bethesda Game
Studios and as anything I could have
dreamed of I see you I see you I see you
we see you because we are you and
together together together we are we are
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
when attaining jump you say how
please welcome Bethesda's senior global
vice president of marketing Pete Hines
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you very much how are you feel
good awesome thank you guys for being
here thank everyone watching around the
world to tuning in to watch our fifth
annual III showcase
this is a night dedicated to those who
love games who loved the incredible
entertainment that games provide this
past year you fought demons on Mars and
Nazis in America you were assassins in
the Empire adventurers in Tamriel and
survivors a lot of us and survivors in
the wasteland and you've embarked on
these amazing adventures on PC console
VR mobile or wherever and however you
choose to play and that's the key
you take the worlds that we create and
you make them yours you share your
experiences with other players with
friends and with families with our games
you've built large global communities
that truly matter this year we want to
give special recognition to the
extraordinary Bethesda community as you
showed as you saw on our opening video
you mean everything to us I've almost
been at this company for twenty years
and when I first started
when I first started one of my first
responsibilities was moderating the
community forums chatting with you and
keep you up to date on our games it was
a great way to start my career path as
des because it was the perfect reminder
of why we do what we do and like so many
others at Bethesda I've spent a lot of
time with you at events around the world
I've enjoyed meeting so many of you and
getting your thoughts and feedback so
tonight we'll be taking time throughout
the show to hear directly from some of
you in the Bethesda community we are
thrilled tonight to show our fans the
lineup of great games we've been
creating just for you including the
premiere of some exciting new games and
we'll go deep on June maternal
[Music]
so if you're ready let's kick it off and
to get an update from our friends at one
of the most celebrated development
studios in the world bethesda game
studios please welcome studio head and
my good friend Todd Howard
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
thank you
great to see everybody we have had an
incredibly exciting Europe as the game
studios given some of that excitement
impressed you're still here
[Applause]
actually over the last year we've had
over 60 million players in our games our
most ever and it's all of you
it's all of you who have made these
worlds what they are take fall out 76
a type of game we'd never done before
had a lot of difficulties at launch and
we got a lot of well-deserved criticism
but the team kept working on it and you
kept playing it and through all of that
something amazing has happened it's
thanks to all of you this game has one
of the best online communities we've
ever seen
we made a post-apocalyptic survival game
where you can do whatever you want and
everybody's nice to each other they
don't go on killing griefing sprees they
leave food and water for the newbies and
wave to each other I don't know about
you this should give us all hope for
Humanity when the apocalypse does come
and we have a lot more in store this
year for fallout 76 but first our latest
game the Elder Scrolls blades is an
early access and thanks to all of you it
became our second straight number one
mobile game after fallout shelter
absolutely incredible
and to tell you what's coming two blades
let me introduce project leader Craig
Lafferty and art director Matt Cara fado
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks Todd it's great to be here at e3
and thanks again to all of you for
making blades number one as someone
who's worked on the elder scrolls for 20
years it's been incredible to bring this
world to your phones in an all new way
we still love those classic dungeon
crawlers and it's clear you do as well
and whether you're exploring a dungeon
or rebuilding your town it's great to be
able to do it wherever you are since its
e3 we're releasing our biggest update
yet featuring all new jobs and solo
arena battles an all new custom jewelry
system and a brand new Dragon Quest line
it has even more but best of all it's
coming out tonight
so download free tonight and give it a
try and we're all so hard at work on our
arena mode for this fall that will
feature PvP your own guild and visiting
your friends towns but most exciting
this year we're also bringing blades to
an all-new platform switch blades
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes please is coming this fall and the
Nintendo switch and yes it's still free
blades is the perfect fit for the switch
you can play on the go on your TV and
with motion controls but best of all
it's cross play and cross progression
with the mobile version so you can so
you can start tonight on mobile and all
your progress will carry over and it's
playable here at e3 in our booth and
Nintendo's yeah
and for those of you playing on mobile
we also have some special rewards for
both our Apple and Google players this
week so download tonight and let us know
what you think thanks again
now let me introduce Jeff and Tom to
tell you what's coming to fallout 76
[Applause]
hi I'm project leader Jeff Gardner and
I'm Co studio director Tom Mustaine on
behalf of everyone but does the game
studios we want to thank the millions of
you who have played with us stuck with
us and helped shape the world the
fallout 76 absolutely
it's incredible what the game has become
you've told us how much you've loved
this year's updates so far from camp
building legendary weapons player
vending and of course the dreaded
sheepsquatch we've also been working on
our biggest update yet
it's called wastelanders and it will
fundamentally change the game it's been
some time since both 76 opened its door
[Applause]
and we all discovered that Appalachia
isn't quite what it used to be we
encountered a lot of things overcame
things I don't think any of us expected
for people to actually come back are you
from that vault
can you help us we've traveled pretty
far there there's hope here in
Appalachia folk rebuilding fighting back
we'll fight to right by your side
we've been everywhere and seen
everything and the one thing we've
learned is this
you've got to claim the wasteland before
it claims
question is are you with us
with them
[Applause]
that's right that's right human NPCs are
coming to Fallout 76
not just NPCs but a full questline new
rewards and as you saw full dialog trees
this is a long-term story we're telling
year one was about the vault doors
opening and all of you settling the
wasteland year two is about people
coming back to reclaim it like previous
Fallout games these characters have
their own stories and goals it's up to
you to choose how to interact with them
and live with those consequences the
wastelanders update is coming this fall
and will be free for all fallout 76
players
and in the spirit of free we're doing
something special just for III fallout
76 is going to have a free trial for
everyone starting tomorrow that's right
it's that's right it's the perfect time
to see what fallout 76 and its growing
community have become we can't wait to
welcome all of you and because so many
of you are going to be joining us
we thought we'd also give you a sneak
peek this week at an all new game-mode
check it out your first test was making
it to the vault now your real trial
begins currently there is no overseer of
vault 51 perhaps you will be the one
we are in serious need of leadership so
I have devised a unique process of
elimination a battle to the death is the
only sure way to judge the superior
candidate to five this should prove
interesting
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there could only be one overseer good
luck
[Music]
[ __ ] yeah we put a battle royale in
fallout 76 right nuclear winter is a
battle royale born from the Fallout
universe from power armor to perk cards
from camp building to contending with
wasteland creatures and of course my
personal favorite nukes it's a great
free addition to an already huge game we
love playing it and we think you will
too
so check out the sneak peak and let us
know what you think remember all of
fallout 76 including nuclear winter is
free to try this week on all platforms
so jump in tomorrow we can't wait to see
you thanks again
remember everything we've talked about
that's coming this year is free we get
to represent hundreds of passionate
developers across four studio locations
in North America
working on multiple projects yes we're
still hard at work on our next-gen RPGs
starfield and of course Elder Scrolls 6
we know how precious these game worlds
are to all of you and they are to us we
know the time you spend in them is
important keep telling us what you love
what you'd like to see us do better
thank you again everybody or for your
support but really even more so I want
to thank everybody for believing in us
thank you please welcome the founder of
tango gameworks mr. Shinji Mikami
[Applause]
hello I'd like to start by getting my
team in Tokyo it's Monday morning there
but they are watching you know house on
us
come in the area
[Music]
tonight I am excited to announce the
next game from tango ghosts
wire Tokyo
it is an action-adventure game in which
you will fight paranormal enemy and the
greatest city of a supernatural evil I
think you rabbit
to tell you more about ghost wire Tokyo
here is creative director at tango Akuma
Nakamura
[Applause]
Wow so many people wow thank you
arigato gozaimasu
[Applause]
such a such a big stage makes me nervous
I'll do my best to speaking English
we are making a new kind of
action-adventure game it's Turkey but
not the survival horror game that we are
known for
people are banishing in Tokyo you must
find out why you will encounter
conspiracies and the occult you have do
it you have to explore the world face
challenges to uncover the torus and save
humanity in the game you will meet
spirit summit angels and survivor that
each have their stories you will need to
ask yourself it is normal or paranormal
I asked myself this question every time
I go to darkest
just kidding just kidding just kidding
we are very excited
let's take a look me tanner thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
don't fear the unknown
attack it
[Applause]
when I'm not playing bethesda games I
work as a mechanical engineer I work in
a hospital I used to work with kids I'm
an electrician I'm an event planner in
real life I'm a Systems Administrator
program assistant for a private school
for children with autism I'm trying to
be an artist I like to think of myself
as one make like back-end systems that
it's really boring
maybe primarily or temporarily I'm a
full-time streamer I got a job I make my
own yarn I'm a social worker teaching
inmates I'm a game developer working at
a video game cafe I've been a doom fan
since the game came out I remember being
into eighth grade and a buddy mind
giving me the shareware demo on three
and a half inch floppy disks
my older brother picked up fallout 3 and
I took his copy and played it when he
wasn't home fallout 4 is like my baby
the scope of that game was just like a
lot bigger than things I was used to
just setting foot in shimmering the
first city that you go to in Somerset it
was amazing you would look out you'd be
like oh I want to go there and then you
could go there which was wild go out
into the world go in any direction that
you want to go the exploration and the
weirdness and the alienness of it I
played oblivion I tell you it probably
saved my life it was one of my first
experiences with a fantasy world that
was that immersive loved the dragon
scatter the Dragons you take down a
dragon you can definitely take down any
illness don't ever stop adding dragons
to your game add dragons to fallout add
dragons to rage add dragons to
everything Mecca Mecca dragons elmore
dragons
[Applause]
at ZeniMax online studios
Thanks thank you everyone Wow thank you
I just want to I just want to shout out
to our friend Greg there the one in the
video that really loves dragons I'm
happy to say Greg the Elder Scrolls
online has dragons right now in fact
players are deep into the season of the
Dragon our year-long story about greed
revenge cat people and of course dragons
tonight's focus on the community
resonates with me and everyone at
ZeniMax online studios because ESO
literally would not exist without you
watching you play the game streaming
telling stories hearing your feedback we
understand that you are the most
important part of the world of Tamriel
thank you thank you for making ESO the
extraordinary adventure it is today the
past year has been a huge success for
eso more Game of the Year awards
millions more players have joined so
many in fact that we recently so many in
fact that we recently added more server
capacity just to support all the news
players interview
eso es Oh just keeps getting bigger and
better just a few days ago we launched
the Elder Scrolls online elsewhere the
latest chapter the latest chapter in the
game where you're able to visit for the
first time the homeland of the Khajiit
as well as control the dead as the new
necromancer class and if you haven't
played it yet
elsewhere is the perfect starting point
for new players when we announce season
of the Dragon we kicked it off by
showing you a video about how dragons
were Unleashed on elsewhere and we ended
with a cliffhanger
now I'm really excited to show you what
happens next check out the world
premiere
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's right another cliffhanger you may
have recognized the return of size' Han
the legendary Red Guard sword master
he's the legendary Red Guard sword
master you met as part of the original
five companions he's back as the leader
of the dragon guard a group a group of
dragon hunting warriors you've seen in
other Elder Scrolls games he'll be
featured in our fourth quarter Story DLC
named dragon old which will complete the
season of the Dragon we've got a lot
more to share about the return of Sai in
the dragon guard which we'll unveil at
QuakeCon later this summer before then
keep an eye out for a dungeon dlc
adventure called scale breaker which
you'll see in August
thank you so much for your support of
the Elder Scrolls online
we're humbled by your enthusiasm your
enthusiasm for the game motivates us
every day you guys are seriously awesome
thank you
but
I have something else to talk about the
Elder Scrolls online isn't the only game
in development at ZeniMax online studios
we have several other projects one of
which we're ready to reveal tonight and
to tell us all about it is the game's
creative director Kiera slit
[Applause]
hi everyone
and now for something completely
different
imagine a classic Saturday morning
cartoon in free-to-play mobile game form
let's take a look
[Music]
commander ji
[Music]
so there's a new branch on commander
Keens family tree and they're heading to
iOS and Android if you're hearing about
Commander Keen for the first time it was
one of the first PC action games created
by ed software in the early 90s it
starred boy genius Billy blaze whose
alter-ego Commander Keen protected earth
all of us at ZeniMax online studios want
to give a really big thanks to our
friends at ed for trusting us to deliver
our modern take on this classic game
so tonight as we introduce Commander
Keen to a new generation of players
we're also introducing the next
generation of heroes meet Billy and
Billy twin geniuses who follow in their
famous father's footsteps the new
commanders are of course funny and
powerful but the game is also full of
enemies allies and some really bad bad
guys
the twins build wacky gadgets from
household items to save the earth from
certain alien destruction drag-and-drop
gadgets to summon allies attack enemies
and move through the environment choose
from a caboodle of contraptions to
conquer challenges and try saying that
five times fast the twins go on
adventures in story mode which tells
some of the classic Commander Keen tales
as well as a whole bunch of brand new
ones in story mode you'll overcome
aliens collect power-ups and explore
Mars and beyond you can also go helmet
to helmet with other players in battle
mode a real-time head-to-head race
through an alien landscape where you
need to control checkpoints and claim
the flag to gain ultimate victory
Commander Keen we'll soft launch this
summer on iOS and Android phones
so please go visit go keen comm to pre
register to receive unique in-game
rewards and hot commander keen launch
updates we really can't wait to kick
some asteroid with you at all
thanks
[Music]
[Applause]
Thank You Kira epithets de we like you
love mobile games in addition to blades
and the upcoming Commander Keen millions
of you have enjoyed fallout shelter
which has now reached over 150 million
downloads and Counting for fans of
collectible card games we brought the
Elder Scrolls legends to mobile so you
could experience the Elder Scrolls in a
new way
this year the Legends community has
continued to grow thanks to a lot of
upgrades new features and new content
it's a great experience for a night of
gaming or a quick match over a cup of
coffee
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
make your play
[Music]
[Applause]
see Dragons if you enjoy other card
games we're looking for something that
provides a little deeper challenge you
can download legends for free on the App
Store and begin playing tonight legends
next expansion moons of elsewhere will
be available on June 27th for PC Mac
mobile and tablet you can head over to
Bethesda net to get a glimpse at the new
cards and content or play it this week
in our booth I'll see you there clapping
now speaking of new content three weeks
ago we released rage - and now insanity
rules and now insanity rules for
millions of players around the world but
we wanted to do more than just deliver a
critically acclaimed open-world shooter
we've already added community challenges
that reward you just for having fun in
the wasteland and we've got a lot more
planned with new features rolling out
this week the world of Rage 2 will
become even more unpredictable and even
more insane take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all around it is destructibility stand
women red barrel drop away
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh that's my next tattoo
[Music]
eeny meeny miny back
[Music]
[Applause]
I got a tremendous surprise for you all
[Music]
[Music]
please welcome executive producer at
machinegames
jerk Gustafson
[Applause]
hello everyone after liberating America
from the Nazi scum in Wolfenstein to the
new Colossus this year we take you back
to Europe with two new Wolfenstein games
first we are bringing Nazi killing into
virtual reality with with Wolfenstein
cyber pilot as a hacker working for the
French Resistance you will take control
of Nazi war machines and turn them
against their creators cyber pilot will
be available this July and it's playable
this week in our e3 booth
and if you haven't put Nazis in VR you
don't know what you are missing but as I
said we have two new Wolfenstein games
this summer we are going to be launching
Wolfenstein Youngblood
with a gameplay experience that is
bigger than any previous Wolfenstein
game you will have more weapons and
weapon upgrades than ever before more
ways to customize your playstyle and of
course even more evil Nazis to kill and
in Youngblood
you can kill those Nazis with a friend
yes Wolfenstein is going co-op young lot
is set in the 1980s two decades after
the new Colossus BJ blaster which is
missing in nazi-occupied Paris and it's
up to his twin daughters yes and so to
track him down in Youngblood you can
still play by yourself or you can
partner with a pal to double up on
shooting stabbing and killing Nazis
check it out
[Music]
Paris Nazi country that's where Papa is
so that's where we're going we to find
him together
I may have an assignment suitable for
two Nazi killers such as yourselves
[Music]
[Music]
the stewardesses
[Music]
[Music]
like our second Joseph
[Music]
Wolfenstein young Lord releases on
PlayStation 4 Xbox one
Nintendo switch and PC on July 26
and if you can't wait stop by our III
booth to play this week thank you
and now I like to welcome to the stage
my dear friends from arcane Leon who
worked with us on these two Wolfenstein
games Binga and Sebastian
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we love you too hi I'm Gingka back Abba
and Game Director or attacking Leo moose
wha I'm semester mutant our director and
this seems to you so along with
partnering with our good friends at
machine games on Wolfenstein we've been
working on other projects at our King
Leo and tonight we're excited to
announce our latest first person action
game it's something innovative stylish
and different from anything we've done
before let me begin by saying Bienvenue
to the frozen item of black reef this is
a place of mystery where looks can kill
the game takes place during what we say
in French is the free time of madness
and now that we've given you a small
taste of the world
let us introduce you to our two deadly
rivals Colt and Juliana
[Applause]
[Music]
this place isn't a paradise it's a
prison
out here out here we're trapped we're
free in this endless eternal cycle
[Music]
[Music]
my life's purpose is on this island
and I can't let this go on any longer
[Music]
the more days I repeat the longer that
I'm out here the more Sydney I am
[Music]
the only way to protect the cycle the
only way to break this cycle mr. Kenyon
[Music]
[Music]
tom is on Marcel
[Music]
[Applause]
this loop combines a mind-bending story
with meticulously designed levels and of
course arcane signature gameplay that
lets you approach every situation anyway
like because in the endless clash
between these two extraordinary
assassins how you play is up to you plus
I think it's very [ __ ] cool
excuse my french yeah maybe maybe you
should have said that in French actually
maybe maybe not
but but it's also pretty [ __ ] true
because we will take you on a trip
unlike any other and we really hope that
you enjoyed the ride merci beaucoup
thank you very much
it's a wonderful way to get away from
all the pressures in life I think the
sense of community has really helped me
as a person because I'm typically very
isolated it's definitely very
confidence-building it's brought me out
of my shell and stop being an introvert
I could like be a hero and do all these
things you find really creative really
fun really talented people meet people
who are in my group that I've only known
as a character probably made one first
oh why did I have in real life the games
that you bring out just helps people
honestly my parents were refugees from
the Vietnam War which is why I'm also
fascinated by elements of war playing
these games just kind of put me out of
the worry and the stress I was in a dark
place for a while and I told myself I
wasn't going to be there anymore and so
now the only dark places that I'm
allowed to go or in dungeons and ESO
just being someone who is LGBTQ it's
nice to be able to sit down and play
these games and feel accepted for who I
am it's really nice to see that the
storyline has some sort of emotional
effect on me as a player and I just
really admire the creativity that goes
into the process of making these big
worlds with these amazing stories
[Applause]
building these fantastic worlds and
telling these stories comes from passion
to deliver the very best experiences for
our players hi i'm james Aultman
director of publishing a bethesda
and I'm Robert Duffy chief technology
officer at heed software
tonight we have some exciting new
technology just show you that can
dramatically improve gaming from
millions so for the past two decades
we've approached game development not by
looking at what is possible today but
with a vision of what can be possible
tomorrow and at Bethesda we're proud of
our legacy of innovation we're again and
again we've changed the industry we were
the first to use physics based engines
for sports games we were groundbreakers
with go anywhere do anything open-world
RPGs we are the inventors of the
first-person shooter which is now the
world's most popular form of gaming we
are pioneers in downloadable content and
the first to bring mods to consoles and
actually since we first brought mods to
consoles in 2016 there have been 1
billion mod downloads for Fallout in
Skyrim
we of course developed the first
commercially viable VR technology
revealed in our III booth in 2012 yes
that is the original VR headset held
together by tape and worn by our very
own Tim Willits
and of course we are well known as
developers of best-in-class
engine technology with our ed tech
engine in its innovation and creativity
is in our DNA and all of these advances
were done with one goal in mind to
improve player experiences so tonight we
have exciting new technology to announce
we're going to show you the result of
years of research and development
cutting-edge game engine based
technology we've developed specifically
for game streaming now we'd like to
introduce you to Orion
Orion is a tremendous breakthrough in
streaming technology it is our name for
a group of patented technologies that
optimize game engines for performance in
a cloud environment
Orion can work with any game engine and
will improve player experiences no
matter which game you're playing or
whether you're streaming on stadia on X
cloud or another streaming platform so
how does a Ryan work the exciting game
streaming services you've been hearing
so much about have largely focused on
hardware solutions to address the
complex challenges of streaming there's
a lot of words we use start parties in
developing game engine software and took
a different approach by incorporating
Orion technology at the game engine
level we're able to stream game content
up to 20 percent faster per frame
leading to a dramatic reduction in
latency in addition an Orion enabled
game can stream with up to 40% lower
bandwidth and happily for game
developers or Ryan technology is easy to
integrate with your game build with our
sdk what does that mean for you it means
that streaming games will be faster and
better with Orion and Orion
substantially reduces the cost of
streaming for players and for publishers
so it won't matter if your friends and
family are sucking up all the bandwidth
or if you live far away from a data
center with Orion you'll still be able
to stream your game at max settings
now as with any new computer technology
one mask one must ask the question can
it play do good question
can it stream an unrelenting fluid
first-person shooter with native 4k
resolution at 60 frames per second let's
see I'd like introduce
I might introduce shale Williams tech
specialist for mid software who is
showing you just that here live on stage
is streaming in Orion enabled doom 2016
right now to that mobile device as you
can see there is no reduction in visual
fidelity
that's doom at 60 frames per second
without perceptible latency and we want
you all to experience this powerful
streaming technology yourself as as we
test and refine it so for a chance to be
among the first in the world to stream
doom 2016 for free all you need to do is
join the doom Slayers Club by
registering at Slayers Club comm tonight
everybody could use a little more doom
in their lives and we'll see you in hell
[Applause]
what you interfere with now this paper
than you
continue
[Music]
but every loss
it is written
it is their time to give penance
you are but one man
they are no longer your people for safe
[Music]
[Applause]
that was awesome this is awesome thank
you so so much I'm Marty Stratton the
executive producer of doom eternal and
I'm and I'm Hugo Martin the game's
creative director
as you just saw we're not just building
a world for Doom it's in the entire
universe earth is on the brink of
annihilation it's being consumed by
demons and your crusade to save it will
take you across dimensions to locations
never seen before in doom from heaven
and hell to the Sentinel homeworld and
beyond yeah
there is so much to see and discover but
doom is first and foremost about
gameplay and doom eternal promises to be
the ultimate power fantasy the fun comes
from mastering the experience because
you are the doom Slayer the strongest
fastest demon killer in existence and
nothing can stand in your way of course
the challenge in Doom is all about
handcrafted combat but also engaging
level design and in doom eternal the
game always has something that's new to
throw at you even deep into the campaign
let's take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you know it's it's so important to
us that in software that every aspect of
the gameplay has real meaning to you the
player every enemy is different every
weapon has a purpose and every decision
you make really counts the only path to
victory in Doom eternal is to
aggressively control the fight with
amazing agility powerful guns and
critical resources that's right I'll
tell you we absolutely can't wait for
you to play it and some of you won't
have to wait too long if you are lucky
enough to be in the room tonight
you'll have a chance to play it
immediately following the show
and for those not here but at e3 this
week we'll have doom eternal playable in
the Bethesda booth all week yeah but
enough talk let's see how it all comes
together and watch as this perfect
killing machine goes to work
[Applause]
I'm charting a flight path to Mars
calculating thrust vectors jaqen three
planetary entry chains prepare for
turbulence
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
Thanks all right that was classic yeah
that was awesome thank you
we're so excited because the gameplay
that you just saw is just a piece of
what you're going to play this week at
e3 yeah but I've been a lot of your
wondering when do we get to play doom
eternal at our home well you don't have
to wait too much longer
not quite tomorrow
[Applause]
but doom eternal will release on
November 22nd
we're very excited about that and we've
got something really special for Dhoom
fans an amazing collector's edition
we're really proud oh yeah yeah that's
that's an actual helmet yeah we you
could wear it you could wear that thing
this guy's guys already got it that's
right
already about it he's already got one on
alright well we've got one more thing we
know that you've been waiting to hear
about our totally new doom multiplayer
experience we call it battle mode we've
been developing this in-house it did and
it's unlike anything you've played
before yeah we've been so pumped I did
to share this with you this is pure doom
but with your friends we're two player
controlled demons take on one fully
loaded Slayer in a fight to the death
this is a first-person fighter where
it's demon strategy versus Slayer skill
you know we can't wait because we know
you'll love the different play styles of
the various demons because each has
unique movement attacks and abilities
they can even spawn AI demons to control
the battlefield and help you take down
the Slayer its strategic competitive and
it's a ton of fun and we can't wait to
share more details with you this year at
QuakeCon let's write a lot more to share
at QuakeCon but before we go we do want
to take a first look at Doom eternals
new multiplayer on behalf of our amazing
team at it in dallas and frankfurt
germany we want to thank you all so much
for your support
thanks everyone
[Applause]
fight
[Music]
[Music]
Slayer album critical
Slayer killed round two
[Music]
so
[Music]
final round fight
[Music]
another round of applause please from
Marty Hugo and all of our presenters
tonight
and for everyone at our studios around
the globe that have worked so hard in
the great games you've seen tonight we
say thank you
20 19 marks 25 years of doom so to
celebrate we will be going all-out with
doom at QuakeCon this summer we're
adding a whole host of panels and
activities dedicated to doom which we
call Duke on deck see what we did there
and he took out the quake and put him
[Applause]
but you hope you can come hang out with
us in Dallas at our inaugural event in
London if you can't please tune in
online until then go to Bethesda net for
more info on all the games you saw
tonight if you hear at e3 this week
we'll have hands-on with many of our
games
so be sure to stop by our booth in the
meantime thanks for playing thanks for
watching and thanks to all of you for
being part of the Bethesda community
have a great night
[Applause]
[Music]
epazote we're in the business of
creating heroes Chilkoot and i think you
morning but the true hero is you
it's like we hand you this malleable
clay and you do these extraordinary
things that we never could have imagined
we get to build these worlds in these
communities and you all come in and you
play and you bring these worlds that we
create to life you helped us build reach
your wills you add meaning to everything
we do we are glad you're here we're so
glad you're here see you the heroes see
Jenny come to the heroes oh [ __ ] I don't
have a drink to you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to game sports
coverage of e3 2019 if you're here you
probably just saw Bethesda the press
conference I don't know I'll get a steak
on it it's kind of underwhelming for a
very long time and then it got to be
pretty awesome in couple ways let's all
go down the list but first off how are
predictions if you're here for the
pre-show we made predictions about what
would happen why o reason oblivion no
moral remasters know dishonored switch
but archaic arcane Leon what it was
fallout collection but the switch that
didn't happen okay let's just go down
the list they did a lot of housekeeping
I'd say we kind of we were talking about
it before in the pre-show where we said
if we're gonna if we wasn't wondering if
they were gonna really own up and just
be very candid about fallout 76 and good
on them they were yeah Todd with his
little his little stand-up routine at
the beginning yeah tongue-in-cheek about
it at first but then they he just
straight-up said he's like like we got a
lot of well as their criticism but you
guys stuck around some people did and
they're it's it's one of those games
where like I don't like fall at 76 but
there are some cool things that happen
within it there are cool communities
I've sprung up that do certain things or
like this there's like this cannibal
Club that I was reading about that yeah
but they're adding human NPCs yeah
there's gonna be MPC something it's so
weird to be living in a time when
Bethesda announces that they're bringing
human NPCs to a game at a press
conference and everyone's cheering dude
I was like I was I wanted to say to them
you know you'd have a whole theater of
people and millions of people are
watching you show us a little more but
no they are owning it they talked a
little bit about a year to stuff with
Fallout 76